hello everyone and welcome to the finals
of the 2021 fiji world cup uh but not
really this is actually the clash for
the third place between vladimir pedosev
and
magnus carlsen the clash for first place
between uh
sergey karyakin and young sister of duda
uh for those of you who do not wish to
learn the result of that game uh you
know skip some 10 seconds
uh now but it ended in a draw
uh and it was a really really quick one
uh there wasn't really much much to show
there so we're skipping straight to this
one which has a lot more action as the
title suggests
uh so without further ado let's check it
out and see what
vladimir was able to do with the white
pieces against the world champion so
let's check it out
uh we have d4 uh magnus replies with
knight to f6
c4 g6 and now uh as magnus is ready to
go for the king's indian defense he
wants to avoid any
uh well well analyzed line so he goes
for h4 and this is nothing new
uh in 2021 this is uh perfectly normal
to advance your uh
flank pawn as soon as the opponent plays
something like g6 or b6
uh we have bishop to g7 by magnus knight
to c3 and
now d6 we have e4 grabbing here the
entire center
knight to c6 by magnus and the d5 now
challenging the knight knights to e5 and
bishop to e2
and here uh there are some moves that
exist in this position c6 a very often
played move
uh but magnus doesn't want to allow h5
at any point
bishop to e2 has been played so uh white
gained control of the h5 square so h5
might be played so he plays h5 himself
and it is now as of move seven that we
have a completely new game
so very very interesting let's see uh
what happened
uh we have bishop to f4 by vladimir and
now castles by magnus
we have knight to f3 uh and magnus
trades here we have knight captures on
f3 but now
not capturing with the bishop you could
do this but g captures on f3
is kind of a classier way to play you
gain this massive center and now you
have the g
file to use for for attacking purposes
if uh
if magnus allows it also maybe moves
like queen to d2 bishop to h6 training
of the dark square bishops
are possible at some point so here c6 by
magnus he undermines the center now and
queen to d2 preparing this bishop to h6
mu
so first magnus plays c captures and d5
c captures and now
uh magnus wants to shift this knight
over to c5 for example to put more
pressure on the center and open up
this dark square bishop's diagonal but
he doesn't want to allow bishop to h6 so
first king to h7 it's a very important
move to play
and now a4 by vladimir uh grabbing more
space here on the queen side we have
knight
to d7 by magnus now the knight can come
to c5
and now a5 so white grabs more space on
the queen side
and the king is still on e1 so you're
not castling king side you're not
castling queenside
uh what what can you do here well magnus
will definitely try to attack this white
king but
if he shifts all of his attention to the
queen side or the center of the board
then white might be even able to castle
at some point in the game
as long as the rook or the king don't
move uh so here you have to decide
whether you want to go knight to c5 do
you want to maybe
challenge this structure with b6 but
magnus chooses the
uh the the f5 move to challenge this
very strong central structure so
f5 uh and now if you go after this pawn
for example he captures an f5 rook
captures
it it's actually a pretty good position
for black uh point being if you play
something like bishop d3
you challenge the rook knight to the e5
and now
it's just uh just a better position for
black knight to f3 check is already a
threat
of winning the white queen if you
capture with the bishop then rook
captures with
check so black is perfectly fine here so
instead
after this f5 move we have rooked the a3
by fedossif
uh and now comes knight the e5 so an
excellent square for this knight
uh and now comes uh uh well uh
you you could play a lot of things here
like you could bring the rook to g1
maybe put some pressure on the g file or
maybe play bishop back to g3 or
something but here we have bishop to e3
but now the position is a really really
tricky one and there is
one move that gives black a tiny tiny
advantage but it's such a
such an awesome move that i really want
you to pause the video here and try to
find
this idea while i give you a couple of
seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations uh as there are many
good moves here uh for black there but
there is
only one uh that is this good and the
congratulations to everyone who founded
the movies f4 uh the idea is now that uh
black wants to continue development with
bishop to d7 then bring
the rest of his pieces into the game but
he doesn't want to allow white
to play this f4 move now for example if
you play bishop to d7 a white will play
f4 you could play knight to g4 then
bishop to d4 you counter black's bishop
here
and the white is perfectly fine here by
playing what magnus played f4 here
you're giving up upon but you're really
hindering white's development and
this is going to do wonders for black's
position as you'll see in the game
so bishop captures on f4 there's really
nothing better bishop to d
for now just allows this beautiful pawn
to stand f4 so bishop captures on f4
bishop to d7 and now would you play here
well if you go back now bishop to e3
with
the same idea we can just play rook
captures on f3 and bishop captures
knight captures wins the queen
so uh not an option so here we have
knight to d1
now the rook also helps out with the
defense of the third rank
but now rook captures on f4 magnus
gladly gives up the exchange here as
this dark square bishop was one of the
few
white's active pieces so queen captures
on f4
now comes bishop to h6 grabbing hold of
this diagonal
and forcing the white queen basically in
exile
as you'll see so queen to g3 now comes
queen to f8 putting more pressure here
along the f file and also preparing this
rook to come to c8
and then c1 so here knight to e3
and now comes bishop to f4 pushing the
black queen even further
not a lot of squares for this black
queen sorry for the white queen
uh queen to g2 and now rook the c8 so
for this
beautiful f4 pawn sacrifice and for the
exchange sacrifice magnus got all this
activity
where white doesn't appear to have a
uh it doesn't appear to have a a
playable move now you could consider
something like
kink to d2 maybe try to activate your
your rook this way
uh but it's it's not an easy move to
make so here we have rook to c3
countering
carlson's rook and c8 magnus trades here
captures captures because
white does not have a lot of active
pieces so eliminating uh one active
piece uh makes
white's position uh or you know
even worse so here queen to c8
this is how magnus now activates the
queen and now c4
the pawn is very nicely protected here
but now all that is needed is to bust
open the queen side and this is what
magnus does we have b5 now
threatening to pick up the pawn here but
also just pushing here might also be
nice
so uh a captures on b6 alpha a captures
on b6
and now uh white has to decide what to
do and it's not an easy decision to make
you could make a lot of interesting
moves like king to f1 king to g1 maybe
try queen to f1
you could try castling right away but
this requires you to give back material
if you castle right away bishop to h3
you have to give back the rook and then
well it's probably still black who's
better but
uh you know if you don't find anything
better
maybe maybe it's uh worth uh uh
considering but uh instead after this
eight captures on b6
uh ferocious have just played a queen to
g1
uh sort of a waiting move here maybe now
you can play king to f1 king to g2 and
then maybe activate
the queen and the rook but now comes
queen to a8
now we have king to f1 and now the move
that completely stops all of white's
ideas is
queen to a2 now the king cannot move the
bishop on
e2 would hang so what do you play here
uh we have knights the g2 now pressuring
the bishop here
now queen to a1 with check knight has to
go back otherwise you're going to lose
the bishop here
so knight's the e1 now comes queen to b2
again
uh getting the queen a little bit closer
with the same idea the king now cannot
move
knight back to g2 now comes queen to c1
with check
knights the e1 and now queen to d2
so uh using a bit of zigzagging tactic
to get the queen
uh all the way to d2 and now again if
the king moves the bishop falls so what
can you play here
the problem is knight to g2 no longer
exists as a move because if you play
knight
to g2 then comes uh the the the
well the the greatest move in the game
that was never played because knights
the g2 was never played
uh but uh feel free to pause the video
here and try to figure this out because
it's really a
it's like the ultimate swung while i
give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on figuring out
why night the g2 here was not possible
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show it's
knight to d3 and now there is nothing
for for white
to do here uh there's no move there
there is literally no move that you can
make here that other than you know just
move that
gives away an entire piece let's say
this or let's say this or you know
there's no move you can make here and uh
well
okay there are some moves but all of
them lose lose like terribly like if you
move the knight
knight to the e3 we just play queen to
e1 check and after king to g2 we just
play queen captures on e2
so you blunder an entire piece here and
other than moving the knight
uh you could maybe capture this knight
that's also an option but if you capture
the knight
then queen captures on d3 with check
king to e1
and now we deliver a very nice double
bishop checkmate so bishop d2 check king
the d1 and the bishop to a4 will be
checkmate
so uh amazing stuff here and uh this is
why
if you guys were wondering after queen
to d2 knight the g2
is no longer possible so everything
would lose but congratulations to
those of you who were able to solve this
hypothetical position so
queen the g2 fedorosev now forced the
repeat moves with the queen and play
some useless moves with king to g7
magnus wants to improve the position of
the king a little bit even though he
could strike in the century immediately
with uh with e6 we'll rook the g1
putting some pressure on g6 but it's not
a problem as long as the knight covers
this square
king to f8 queen back to h1 no moves
whatever uh for
whatsoever for white here and now e6
finally magnus goes for this the idea is
of course just captures captures and
then getting a nice pass pawn or
captures captures and then
uh you will be uh well you you will have
a very weak c4 pawn here by white and
it's
going to be very easy to pick it up and
then again promote the b-pawn into a
queen because
white has no active pieces so here uh
you could capture it's not a problem
but here we have rook to g3 here if it
also
tries giving up the exchange here but
magnus is not interested magnus just
continues with e captures on d5 there's
no reason to give an active piece for an
in inactive rook so e captures on the e5
and not
of course not c captures and then
allowing this pawn to start marching
forward
and now we have bishop to f5 so with the
very solid control of the d3 square the
bishop now controls it
the the knight controls it and we can
play some like queen to c1 then
threaten knight d3 going after the
knight here and it's gonna be over very
quickly
so here if it was without a move in in
sight rook back to g1
king to f7 we have rook back to g3
now comes knight to d7 now magnus is
shifting the knight over a little bit
uh to get a more uh well uh precise
position if you will
we looked at g5 philosoph now really
really trying to give up this rook but
now magnus says okay
now you're just being silly now i'm
gonna capture it so bishop captures on
g5
h captures here magnus play knight to
the e5 and it was in this position on
move 41
that vladimir pharosev uh resigned the
game as there is nothing more to be done
here
so really really a spectacular game of
of of such a middle game
swung uh that uh you know i i was not
expecting this but ever since that f4
move that you all of you found that
magnus played you know just to get that
one tempo and
uh you know the good things just just
started happening
uh so yeah here you resign uh there is
no no defending the position let's say
try not
knights to g2 there there are no moves
you can play knight g2
we're just going to play bishop to d3
and that's it there there's no defending
this if bishop characters you just play
queen captures
and wherever the king goes and knight
captures on f3 is just checkmate so
there's no defending this
and if you try a bit of a more resilient
approach you might try queen to g2
just waiting uh then we play queen to c1
we just spin the knight here and after
let's say waiting move knight to d3
again now threatening to just win the
game
if bishop captures we're going to play
bishop captures on d3 with
check king has to move now we're going
to pick up the g5 pawn king has to move
now we're going to pick up the c4 pawn
then this pawn and
there's simply no playing this for white
uh of course vladimir knows this and uh
after knights day e5 he resigned
the game uh but what uh what a
spectacular
uh idea after 95 this bishop to e3
he he totally wanted to play this f4
move but magnus just
stopped it he played that f4 gave up a
pawn and this is how you
sometimes have to play if you know
everything is about that one tempo you
just have to make it
and then none of your opponent's ideas
will will be possible
he will be tied on for the entire game
and also maybe something that you can
use in your own game so
really awesome stuff for magnus we'll
see what uh vladimir will be able to do
in the next classical game with the
black pieces will be
will he be able to equalize and of
course we are returning to the
uh duda versus karjakin match as the
second game is probably going to be a
bit more interesting
with duda having the white pieces uh no
doubt he would very much enjoy ending
this
in the classical time format uh so yeah
that's the game hope you guys enjoyed it
uh i would like to thank jeffrey johnson
david kimura
tom derelo uh alexander trebus and
brendan fukuda for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the video
world cup checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens
in the chess world thank you all i will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day